- My name is Sam DiVine.
I'm 27 years old and I am a salon owner.
My story of becoming a
hairstylist is pretty interesting.
I had been cutting hair
all throughout high school
on all of my friends and playing
and just having a good time.
And I never actually thought
about it as a career path
because it was never brought up to me
that it could be a career path.
And I'm reading this
article and I was just like,
you've gotta be kidding me.
Somebody is charging $800 for a haircut?
That's crazy.
And she's doing every celebrity
and it was incredible.
So I went home and I
did a lot of research,
and I found out that
she was not the only one
and that, you know, that she
wasn't like a fluke situation.
And I decided right then and there,
I was like, that's what I want to do.
Like, that's definitely what I want to do.
So I'm at my salon in this
small town in New Jersey
and I'm talking with my stylist,
and I was like, "hey, like,
this is what I want to do.
"I have no idea where to begin."
And she was like, "You have
to go to Vidal Sassoon,
"hands-down."
When you become a hair stylist
you have a couple different options.
You can open your own salon,
which some people choose to do.
You can go and work, depending
on what state you work in,
because every state has different laws,
but a lot of states allow booth renting,
which means that you will
come into a salon location.
They'll have stations set up
and you pay rent, essentially,
a monthly rent for a station.
Or you can work in a salon
that's commission-based,
which means you're part of a team.
You're part of a culture.
You're part of the entire business.
When you're just starting
out in the industry,
you're gonna have to, essentially,
like, earn your way for a little while.
You're gonna have to prove yourself.
If you would've asked me a month before
I decided that this was
what I was going to do,
I would have told you you were crazy.
I would never open a salon.
I knew absolutely nothing
about running a business
or how to start a business
or anything related to business
other than showing up at work,
doing my clients, and, you
know, collecting a paycheck.
So for me, it was a lot of new learning.
But luckily, I do love to read
and I love to learn new things.
So Google was my best friend.
I Googled absolutely everything endlessly.
Absorbed anything I could read
about opening a new business,
whether it was a hair salon or not,
just figuring out, you
know, what that entailed.
My responsibilities on any given day
is gonna be getting to the salon,
making sure that everything
is ready to run smoothly,
so making sure that the
schedule is correct,
making sure that we're fully staffed,
taking care of the bills,
making sure that, you know, payroll is run
and payroll is processed,
working on my own clients for
a good portion of the day.